for the first time ever i'm grilling the
kardashian jetters
andy cohen grills the kardashian jenners
on their love lives and
headline making scandals welcome to a
sit down
20 seasons in the making a trailer for
the upcoming keeping up with the
kardashians series finale reunion just
dropped
and it is juicy what people don't know
is
you said to me i'm gonna put you in a
car and no one will find you
just leave and i'll take care of it wow
do you think you owe him an apology
absolutely while we wait to find out who
and what they're talking about there
expect plenty more bombshell moments
kim courtney chloe chris kendall kylie
and scott disick
join the bravo star for a two-part
reunion special
which even has chris feeling on edge
in the teaser the family opens up about
ending their show
after 15 years why is the show coming to
an end
we're all feeling a little overwhelmed
we've done it for so long
that all echoes what the show's
executive producer ryan seacrest told et
shortly after news broke that the show
was coming to a close
at some point you're gonna say you know
we did it we had a great run
we're gonna live with a little more
privacy in our lives and i think they
just felt like
now is the time to do it but back to
that kardashian reunion
oh my god andy doesn't shy away from
asking the tough questions
i loved it i thought it was amazing he
digs into the status of chris's
relationship with her ex
caitlyn jenner chris have you forgiven
caitlyn for how she treated you
and grills cocoa on her boyfriend
tristan thompson's past
cheating scandals when tristan first
cheated on you how did you know
it will be done again as for court and
scott he asked them all about their
roller coaster past
do you think your relationship might
have turned out differently if you
hadn't
shared so much of it probably really but
i think the substance abuse
was the deal it was pretty irresponsible
of course
court and scott share three children
together and have both moved on to other
relationships
scott's dating 19 year old model amelia
gray hamlin
while the pooch founder is with blink
182 drummer travis barker
and yes andy asks about that too so do
courtney and travis have your blessing
so i guess we'll have to wait and see
what scott has to say about that
but a source recently told et that scott
and travis quote have never bonded even
when courtney and travis were just
friends
adding quote travis and scott are very
different
i love you and while fans didn't get to
see
court and travis fall in love on keeping
up a source tells e.t that fans can
expect to see the musician on court's
new hulu show with the rest of her
famous fam quote travis is expected to
make an appearance on the kardashians
hulu show
his kids may appear as well but not as
much as he will be featured i love it
until then fans will just have to tune
into part one of the keeping up reunion
when it airs
june 17th on e
you